i know my current events are number one
jon you're on i'm going forward
okay listen so you got a new one i got a
new current event man oh man
this is important did you run through it
with your queen no that did it solo
all right okay so you studied by
yourself this week okay all right
listen all right target margaret uh
keenan
right who is she she's a 90 year old
jewelry
shop assistant okay she was the first
person
to take the vaccine shot oh yeah come on
man
get out come on brian is she in new york
she's in uk
ah she's in the uk she's in the uk love
island
they're they're starting to uh drop the
vaccine right
yeah they're starting to drop now now
the biggest test that i was watching the
news last night
the biggest problem they have now is
convincing the people to take the
vaccine
people are never satisfied man now and
also they said she was like wait till
the vaccine we stand back well there's
something
with them you got to realize i mean it's
fair to not trust certain [ __ ] don't
give me the first batch i'm not saying
i'm not saying like
whatever i'm just saying people have
been lied to in ridiculous ways
yeah from you know i think well yeah i
think the approval and trust in the
government's complaint
that's all very low right now yeah it's
very low right now so
also they say latinas uh uh cover 19 is
spiking they say latinas
latinos only latinas and black people
yeah what are they nice to the black so
not the men no black blacks
no latinos like their death rate's way
higher than a lot of people so the black
people
yeah covet [ __ ] them up so that's why
oh that was
yeah that's why biden that's why biden
came out was like hey we need to get
these vaccines
to the lower income black families and
mexicans
and then you know they're like well why
the [ __ ] do we need we have to take it
first
brian's like dude i'm just trying to
[ __ ] help if you don't take it don't
take it
they're making nurse and people like my
mom works in the hospital so they're
making them take it
and now my mom's like well they're at
the most rest yeah well because
she they were like why would we take it
and we're trying to help the people
first like what if we get sick
and who's going to help us so there's
like it's mandatory for
hospital workers you know yeah they have
to take tv tests like my mom had this oh
yeah do all this but the first vaccine
they have to so you want your nurse
like you want them to take it first they
take tb tests they take all this other
stuff
to be a nurse you know eventually to fly
international you're gonna have to have
some sort of
some for some form of proof that you've
been vaccinated by a copay or you can't
come into that country
it's the same thing if you go to africa
you have to get these shots you got to
get the shots
that's what i'm saying yeah you said
what you're saying you said what what do
you say about them i go to africa what
do you say about the motherland not
going
but you'd rather go and get a vaccine
shot and go to the uk
yeah that's his motherland though you
guys need to understand that's his
motherland
you guys trying to get those malaria and
whatever else shots
hilarious you have to get malaria out
there
because the mosquitoes yeah mosquitoes
and [ __ ] but anyways but yeah the like
nurses yeah they have to take you know
because they're around it nonstop
yeah i mean it makes sense i mean but to
your point yes the thing with black
people
uh i did hear that and i heard a lot of
it had to do with like
uh lack of the the vitamin d levels yeah
so yeah
extremely low in black people because
that's being darker
yeah we don't like to go out in the sun
yeah
no there was a doctor no i don't know
the death rate if coveted with black
people was like really high
yeah a lot of it and what they were
finding out a lot of it was the vitamin
d
levels i'll tell you right now if
they tell me the world will open up i
told you this
i will get that vaccine shot in my
[ __ ] eyeball if i have to yeah
i was waiting for it i could eyeball
that's even more extreme
yes way more i'm trying to one-up you
wear glasses
well i'll take them off you ever have a
shot in your hand
like an iv that's the worst that's right
that's the worst
an iv in the hand that's great brian
come on you know how when you go to the
veins get the veins
so um non-hispanic
blacks and hispanics 2.8 times
where according to this graph yeah or
this little now does it say
they have more underlying health
conditions because that could be sub to
it too
before read the article
hold on so my stepfather got in that's a
pretty big man he's good yeah
my father-in-law got in he has the worst
lungs of anyone i've ever met
and straight but did you see that they
voted that uh they can't do the
businesses and [ __ ] don't have to shut
down la no they overturned it over time
yeah they overturned it but they said
something along the lines of like
it's still not going to open up right
away because we're still technically in
a lockdown
well we're we're under house constraint
so but they do you know i've seen so
many people outside
i was awesome people are unless
lit it was lit i mean my girl was like
just a [ __ ] y'all
all right you can make it mad
judge the bond a lot of my people from
back home like my family and [ __ ] though
they'll reach out to me and they go
no keto up alito uh they'll reach out to
me and be like
are you okay like like you just you're
just sitting at home i'm like
set up some of the video of us in boise
but i'm fine i'm fine
but that's bad
anyways what else you got jen
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son